first thing I want to hit on is that the
the biggest issue that you have is that
most of the time you're looking to
move something into a direction that
rewards you right uh I want to lose
weight because I I feel ugly I don't
look good when I get out of the shower
my knees hurt when I walk upstairs
whatever the rationale is you know I
want to keep up with my kids whatever
the rationale is that you know people
put in their heads
so it's it's some sort of improvement
it's it's something better I want to
make more money I want to get a
promotion I want to move from a Korean
card of a Japanese car from a Japanese
car to a German car whatever it happens
to be whatever your goal might look like
and one of the
most significant reasons one of the
biggest contributing factors I find that
people
don't pay enough attention to is that
look I mean if you want to be rich you
can't hang your you can't hang out with
poor people if you want to be healthy
and fit you can't hang around with
people that aren't healthy and fit you
always become the average of the people
you spend the most time with
that means you're going to have to make
some difficult choices like stop hanging
around certain people stop doing certain
things that you've been comfortable
doing
right the definition of insanity doing
the same thing over and over again
trying to get a different result but
you're continuing to do the same thing
over and over again you never get that
different result
surround yourself with the same losers
that got you to where you're at are not
going to get you to where you want to go
I've always said if you're the smartest
guy in the room you're in the wrong room
get out of the damn room go to a better
room
there's different ways to do it you can
buy your way into a better room you
could you know you could Network your
way into a better room there's many
different ways to do it but the excuses
are endless you know
I'm sure you guys will notice a pattern
by now especially if you watch the
videos on YouTube rather than listen to
the audio recording on the podcasts that
it gets uploaded to
um so for frame for those of you that
listen the vast majority of the guys
that call in with problems in the in
their lives have one very obvious
problem in their life that they don't
seem to address
or take Serious enough and that's their
health that's their weight right
um
I don't give away my my age my year of
birth I'll you know I'll say my a 70s
guy right I was born in the 70s
and there's a lot of guys my age that
don't look like they were born in the
70s they look like they were born in the
60s or 50s in some cases right out of
shape overweight don't have any Style no
masculine frame they sound feminine
if you if you allow this into your life
then you're just going to become part of
that you know it's been said you hang
out with five broke dumb fat losers
you're gonna be the sixth you know if if
their hobbies include sitting around
doing nothing with their lives watching
sports or playing video games for 72
hours straight
you're going to be the sixth right so
guess what it's time for you to make
some tough choices about who you're
going to surround yourself with that's
the number one thing most people get
wrong
right you want to get fit stop hanging
around fat people hang around fit people
right you want to get rich stop hanging
around poor people hang around rich
people right
it's not complex like I said a lot of
the guys that call in my shows it's it's
always the same common theme hey dude
yeah you got a problem with a girl hey
dude yeah you know you got a problem
with whatever at work or something like
that uh have you looked in the mirror
recently because I can see a lot of
extra body weight around your face and
that's all I'm looking at in the screen
so I don't even know what the rest you
look like but something's wrong
right
deal with something that obvious first
right who you surround with and what
you're doing I'll talk about choices in
a moment
one of the other issues that many of you
guys
fall into is you as you limit this to oh
I'm gonna save it for New Year's
why why
do you have to wait for a specific date
to do something about something of [ __ ]
in your life right I took a look at my
training regime around September at the
end of the summer I've been doing boxing
been strength training for years for
decades since I was
since my dad handed me Charles atlas's
guide to lifting weights which is
something that he had from like the 50s
or 60s or something it was like a black
and white or a 40s sort of thing
up in a binder
and uh it's been going on for a long
long time
I wasn't getting it right I'll be honest
with you I wasn't getting it right and I
didn't wait until January 1st to hire a
trainer in September I said I'm not
happy with this I'm gonna I want to get
you know that that leanness going on
that I always was able to maintain when
I was younger and it's and it's harder
as you get older right it's a lot harder
as you get older you have to you have to
really be super disciplined with uh
training technique diet and everything
like that so I hired a personal trainer
he's been great
I've been using them for about six weeks
now and uh feeling amazing getting great
results he's showing me stuff I didn't
even contemplate I've been doing this
for decades I mean you think you know
everything you've done something for ten
thousand hours and then you hire
somebody that was an actual bodybuilder
somebody that was
um judging bodybuilding competitions and
he knows about Aesthetics and physique
he just he just took one look at me he
goes your calves are pathetic you have
no hamstrings and your rear delts suck
we're going to start with those three
areas right right
so I mean you want to make drastic
changes stop waiting to make them take
them immediately surround yourself with
great people and hire experts you know
that can help you anyway the next thing
I want to hit is you don't Define a
specific goal
you don't frame the specific goal
positively like if if you're saying I
want to be rich
well what is what is the benefit to that
like how much more money do you want to
make be specific did you make a hundred
thousand dollars last year what do you
want to make this year 150 200 a mill
right get clear on what the goal looks
like if you're
six foot two and 310 pounds and you
should really weigh about 205 to 210
pounds get clear on what that goal needs
to look like right I mean the first
thing that I do when I see
a aesthetic men's physique competitor
for example like on a
on a
feed or a bodybuilding site or something
like that I'd be like okay that guy
looks like he's about how tall six two
oh cool okay so what does he weigh
because he's got the same frame that I
do all right that's very clear that's
what the goal is right get to 205 206.
what percentage body fat okay that's it
right there get clear right you know you
go looking to define the goal
the wealth self-care whatever it happens
to be you're not defining it clearly
enough take a sharpie this is what I use
come back to the mic in a second
you want to get real serious about it
take a sharpie and write it on your
bathroom mirror right current weight
goal weight just write it down right in
the mirror
I'll have to post a picture at some
point on social media my bathroom mirror
upstairs but I've got
my weight measurements and body fat
percentage all the way down one side of
the mirror and all the way down the
other side of the mirror because I stand
on a scale to to monitor but you can't
manage what you're not monitoring you
know it's as simple as that
so you're not defining the goal
you're not framing the goal positively
like what's the benefit to it what are
you going to do with the extra money
that you're going to make oh you look
exotic cars cool me too what are you
gonna buy well you got your heart set on
what McLaren 600 LT spider very clear
awesome or you want a coupe is it gonna
have a roof scoop on it right do you
have it on your desktop
are you clear and what's what's the
positive frame around it what are you
going to do with it you're going to join
the Exotic Car Club and hang out with me
and we're going to go for rips awesome
you're very clear now right are you
tracking your progress towards that a
weight you know is is simple to track
buy a body fat percentage scale yes I
know they're not accurate but buy a body
fat percentage scale accurate to what
you actually are right now but they're
accurate to your last measurement
right like mine's never accurate mine
says I'm 23 body fat it's way off
but when it it shows me 19 to 23 in a
Range I go from 23 down to 19. I know
that I've dropped
right manage measure sort of thing I go
to my uh coach and he takes a body fat
calipers and he's like nah you're about
13 right now
so
frame it so that you're clear on what
the benefit is to you doing that right
the car the money the weight whatever it
happens to be I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out